[Music]
[Applause]
it is still sinking in
the magnitude of this moment
[Applause]
as soldiers move through these scenes of
Celebration they're given a hero's
welcome
Liberation feels good
[Applause]
[Music]
and they are holding on to it tights
hugely emotional scenes here in the
center of Kirsten the military are
driving through they're playing the
national anthem of people
are just running out uh Tears in their
eyes to express their gratitude for
liberating the city for for coming in
here and bringing it back under
Ukrainian control
these people have lived under nine
months of terrifying occupation it's
easy to understand why they're weeping
tears of relief and joy and Clinging On
to their liberators
the celebrations carry on across the
square all day and it is infectious many
here feared this time may never come and
now they're cherishing it a rare moment
of good news in a war which has caused
so much pain
[Applause]
[Music]
and it is perhaps a reflection of the
strength of the residents that life in
many places carries on as kind of normal
but the smashed up buildings and the
Dark Secrets they contain are hard to
forget
members of Russia's internal security
the FSB were based in this hotel before
it was hit by a Ukrainian artillery
strike
from here they enforced moscow's rule of
Oppression
those Gathering outside say many people
in the city will simply disappeared
foreign
under occupation was a life lived in
fear
and although freedom is a powerful
currency basic Services remain Cuts
there's no power and there are cues like
this everywhere for water
believe
the Russians spent their time here
talking of a new motherlands the posters
for the Sham referendum still hang heavy
over the city
but Vladimir Putin's illegal annexation
and his claim Kirsten is Russia forever
means nothing when the people here have
a different idea of who they want to be
[Music]
the truth is moscow's forces built
nothing and destroyed much this is the
TV tower which they blew up as they left
cutting telephone services and the
internet
you can see the antonovsky bridge it's
been continually damaged during this
conflict but those sections there were
blown by the Russians when they
retreated to the Eastern Bank and just a
couple of kilometers from where I'm
standing that is their new defensive
position
for now though it's about reconnecting
with the outside worlds soldiers in the
Square have set up satellite internet so
people can tell their loved ones they're
okay
feels like Freedom At Last it feels like
a big future is coming here did you ever
think this moment would come
from very first day I knew it was coming
true for nine months of occupation yes
yes and what was that like
you have to to have something which you
live for and this was the moment to live
for
I know Liberation is not something
happening uh uh every year it's
something in five generations and it's a
moment to stay
there is anger here too at what Russia
has done to Ukraine with many trying to
tear down any reminders of what they've
had to endure
[Music]
[Applause]
and with the kremlin's forces in Retreat
people here are willing their military
to free the rest of the country soon
Alex Rossi Sky News in Carson City